do you have any plans to visit the
border we've been to the border
so this whole this whole this whole
thing about the border
you haven't been to the border i and i
haven't been to europe
and i mean i don't know i don't
understand the point that you're making
i'm not discounting the importance of
the borders
i know republicans have certainly come
at you on this but
democratic congressman cuellar has a
border district has said to the
you and the president come you can't see
this listen i care about what's
happening at the border
i'm in guatemala because my focus is
dealing with the root causes of
migration
there may be some
who think that that is not important
but it is my firm belief that if we care
about what's happening at the border
we better care about the root causes and
address them
let's bring in louisiana senator john
kennedy good morning to you senator
good morning good morning so everyone's
been asking when is she going to go to
the border it's been 76 days since she
was appointed as the border czar yet
she's
yet to go to the border and uh lester
holt pressed her on it
what do you think about her answer she
said we have been and then he pressed
and said no
you really haven't been well i think
most americans
can can see what's going on here
the bible administration believes in
open borders
they may say otherwise but most of the
members of the bid
administration that i've talked to
believe that vetting people at the
border
is racist they they uh
they don't they support legal
illegal and legal immigration most
americans support illegal immigration
but they don't support illegal
immigration but
i think the reason the vice president
went to uh
to guatemala and and met with president
uh
jamatay is to offer him
billions and billions of american
taxpayer dollars to try to make his
country better and with
no disrespect but that's like giving um
it's like giving whiskey and car keys to
a teenager
president jamatay is an authoritarian
uh he presides over a corrupt
administration
they're probably going to steal the
money uh
corruption is rampant the drug cartels
work
or run things and frankly president
jamatay
wants his people to come to america
because they come here they get through
illegally
they get a job and they send money back
home which helps the gdp of guatemala
now you don't have to be einstein's
cousin to figure all this out
senator i i her answer was so
inappropriate and so inadequate
i think it needs to be underlined she
said i didn't go to europe either
and giggles and then says we've been to
the border no you haven't
i mean it's it's as if she didn't
pre-think it it reminds me when she was
a candidate
and failed so precipitously but in the
big picture
she they can't be happy with what's
happening 170 000 people coming across
the border
military bases being converted other
structures being put
up money is coming pouring out in one
way it's a simple answer to say they
want open borders
but i think it's more complex than that
are they just incompetent
no i don't i i thought at first they
were
but but i'm convinced now that they
believe in open borders
and in in some uh part it's because some
members of the byte administration
just just think they're sympathetic they
want
they think anybody wants to come to
america should be able to
others take a more cynical view it's
about votes and power
it's dangerous i can tell you that we
have people from all over the world not
just nicaragua
and guatemala and el salvador we have
people from all over the world trying to
make their way to mexico so they can
come into the united states of america
and we don't have the slightest idea who
they are what they're going to do when
they get here
and that's uh that's not a very prudent
way to run an immigration system i don't
know anybody else
in the world who does it that way except
the united states of america
yep we're number one in that department
hey uh senator your colleague from west
virginia joe manchin is getting a lot of
publicity
because over the weekend he wrote an
op-ed for a local paper out in west
virginia where he said
that he would vote against the for the
people act
which was you know uh which would
essentially federalize all elections
flies in the face of the constitution
uh and the headlines have been he's
really gotten baked
over at cnn they say joe manchin just
totally screwed democrats
washington post on the opinion page joe
manchin retreats to fantasyland
and sticks america with the consequences
you know he's been very clear from the
get-go he does not want to blow up the
filibuster
because if you blow up the filibuster
you essentially blow up the senate
well here's what i think is going on and
you're correct uh uh senator manchin
they've hit him with that
with everything but a chair they they
called him every name
in the book they they haven't started
talking about his mama yet but they
probably will
here's what i think is going on this
isn't a news flash
uh the leadership of the democratic
party took a hard left and kept driving
there are two groups in charge uh the
walker reestas who have contempt for
america and the managerial elite
who have contempt for the american
middle
class i refer to them as the
the vanilla soy extra foam latte crowd
senator mansion's not a member of each
either one of those groups
and he's been around this place a long
time and my experience with joe
is he's intelligent he exercise
exercises power
maturely and he understands that if we
get rid of the filibuster
it will blow up the senate you don't
think that uh
the minority party in this case
republicans if schumer gets rid of the
filibuster are just going to go
quiet quietly into that good night every
reaction
has an equal and opposite reaction right
you guys might leave out uh you might
storm out and not give them a quara
the interesting thing brian is is that
senator schumer doesn't quite know how
to handle this
um you know that feeling when you get up
in the morning
and you've got to go to the bathroom but
you don't want to get out of bed
you know that's kind of where chuck is
he he doesn't
he just doesn't know quite know what to
do here and if i were chuck
i'd go to bed i'd get out of bed but and
when one door closes he's not going to
bust the filibuster when one door closes
sometimes you need to get a hammer and
nails
and and make sure that sob stays shut
and move on
that's what chuck ought to do you know
um
we always learn a lot about you senator
during this visit
we think we thank you very much for
joining us and we look forward to seeing
you next week sir as he runs for the
election thank you six more years